künstliche intelligenz ist ein riesiges
thema die einfluss reicht von den
algorithmen die entscheiden welche
inhalte wir jeden tag online sehen über
die ersten selbstfahrenden autos bis hin
zu komplexen spielen in dem karree
algorithmen inzwischen oft besser sind
als wir menschen immer mehr projekte
unternehmen start-ups künstler und hobby
programmierer arbeiten mit ki und auch
hier auf dem kanal spreche ich wie ihr
wisst sehr gerne über dieses thema
künstliche intelligenz von künstlicher
intelligenz günstig intelligenz
künstliche intelligenz künstliche
intelligenz mit hilfe von künstlicher
intelligenz aber was kann die wirklich
ist und wie sie funktioniert das
verstehen tatsächlich die wenigsten
deswegen haben sich das max planck
institut für intelligente systeme und
das doktor watson team zusammen getan
wir wollen eine große video serie über
ki machen und dabei zeigen wie
künstliche intelligenz tatsächlich
funktioniert und wie sie gerade
erforscht wird
helfen wird uns dabei annika buchholz
sie ist promovierte physikerin und
wissenschaftsmanagerin am max planck
institut für intelligente systeme in
tübingen
dort arbeitet und forscht sie in der
abteilung für empirische in friends das
bedeutet sie beschäftigt sich mit
verschiedenen aspekten des maschinellen
lernens und der frage wie man daten zum
sprechen bringen kann wie sie selber
sagt annika wird uns in den nächsten
folgen begleiten und hat uns auch schon
nach tübingen ans max-planck-institut
eingeladen da werden wir dann in einer
der kommenden folgen hin fahren und uns
lernende roboter anschauen freue ich
mich schon mega drauf aber jetzt geht es
erstmal los mit folge eins und
generativen modellen
[Musik]
die cisco xanten
es sei jetzt schon okay sind wir mal
ehrlich künstliche intelligenz ist ein
buzzword und wird inzwischen auch sitzen
nicht alles drauf geklatscht was mit
computern irgendwie zu tun hat dabei ist
eigentlich nur ein überbegriff der so
von den leuten die damit arbeiten kaum
verwendet wird denn wirklich intelligent
ist da noch nicht viel
stattdessen ist die rede meist eher von
maschinen learning also maschinellem
lernen und innerhalb des maschinellen
lernens gibt es noch einmal viele
verschiedene modelle die alle in ihrer
funktionsweise und ihren fähigkeiten
unterschiedlich sind was ist ein modell
ein modell beschreibt quasi die theorie
eines intelligenten programms was ist
die idee dahinter und was will man damit
erreichen
dann braucht es noch ein algorithmus der
diese idee implementiert und eine menge
daten mit denen der algorithmus
trainiert werden kann
da unterscheiden wir zwischen zwei
verschiedenen arten von modellen auf der
einen seite gibt es diskriminiere
modelle die können zum beispiel
wir geben ein objekt eine aussage
darüber machen mit welcher
wahrscheinlichkeit es sich dabei um ein
apfel handelt oder hingeben ein anderes
objekt mit welcher wahrscheinlichkeit
handelt es sich hierbei um einen apfel
und auf der anderen seite gibt es
generative modelle die lernen wirklich
was die eigenschaften von einem apfel
sind und können deshalb auch ein apfel
erzeugen ein beispiel für
diskriminierung modelle sind neuronale
netze von den habt ihr sicherlich schon
mal gehört sie sind der funktionsweise
des menschlichen gehirns nachempfunden
und können schon einige sehr
beeindruckende dinge tun wie zum
beispiel bilder klassifizieren also
einordnen
aber es gibt eben nicht nur neuronale
netze sondern zum beispiel auch
entscheidungs bäume mit denen man
entscheidungen treffen und auch objekte
klassifizieren kann auch das ist eine
form des maschinellen lernens also kam
aber von diesen anderen formen hört man
nicht so häufig wichtig ist dass
diskriminiere modelle immer nur eine
bedingte wahrscheinlichkeit lernen also
zum beispiel gegeben ein input wie zum
beispiel dieses bild hier wie
wahrscheinlich ist es dass das ein ab
ist generativen modelle hingegen lernen
nicht die bedingte wahrscheinlichkeit
sondern die gesamte wahrscheinlichkeit
verteilung
man könnte auch sagen dass sie lernen
die zusammenhänge zu verstehen nicht nur
ist das ein apfel sondern so sieht ein
apfel generell aus und auch hier gibt es
verschiedene modelle zum beispiel auto
encoder sie bestehen aus zwei teilen im
ein cola und einen decoder
das kann sich vorstellen wie ein
verschlossener und entschlüsseln und
vorne gibt mandaten rein
die wahl endet und dann hat man mal so
eine kompakte darstellung dieser daten
umgeht dem decoder kann man nie wieder
entpacken das trainieren so man gibt
daten rein und sagt spucken wenn die
gleichen daten wieder raus was natürlich
erstmal nicht so spannend
wir produzieren aber das kann man zum
beispiel nutzen um daten zu komprimieren
dann weiterzugeben und mit dem
decoderkarten entschlüsseln
dann gibt es noch eine spezielle form
von auto oder der variationen auto oder
da fordert man dass die darstellung der
daten in der mitte bestimmten
statistischen verteilung folgen und dann
kann man den decoder separat nehmen und
als generator nutzen das heißt man gibt
einfach zufälliges raus darauf und in
spuckt neuen datensatz aus zum beispiel
bild und das ist da wirklich ein
generatives modell das waren jetzt
einige der bekanntesten und wichtigsten
modelle in diesem bereich aber natürlich
gibt es auch hier noch viel viel mehr
die derzeit wohl erfolgreichsten
generativen modelle sind wahrscheinlich
die sogenannten ganz und genau die
wollen wir uns heute mal genauer
anschauen
ganz steht für jennifer seven network
also erzeugendes gegnerisches netzwerk
klingt erstmal vertrag ist aber ziemlich
cool
denn diese konstrukte können zum
beispiel kunst fälschen oder bilder
erzeugen von objekten die total echt
aussehender wustlich wirklichkeit gar
nicht gibt und das prinzip ist dass man
zwei neuronale netz nimmt und
gegeneinander trainiert also ein
bisschen gegeneinander ausspielt und so
lernen die dann eben diesen neuen sachen
zu erzeugen die idee hinter diesem
modell ist echt spannend und ziemlich
genial deswegen will ich darauf noch mal
genauer eingehen
wir haben zuerst einmal einen generator
wenn wir ihn gustaf und einem
diskriminiert dave gustavs aufgabe ist
es bilder zu erzeugen die es eigentlich
gar nicht gibt zum beispiel von äpfeln
aber das geht auch mit gesichtern mit
gemälden und sogar mit videos
dave aufgabe wiederum ist es zwischen
echten und dem von gustav gefälschten
bildern zu unterscheiden
zu beginn sind die beiden noch total
unerfahren in ihrem job und machen noch
viele fehler
aber mit der zeit pushen sie sich
gegenseitig immer wenn gustav ein
besseres bild erzeugt muss dave sich ins
zeug legen und besser im detektieren
werden
und dann beginnt das spiel von vorne
denn dann muss darf wiederum bessere
fälschungen machen
am ende gewinnt aber immer gustav der
generator zumindest solange das training
erfolgreich war
denn dann sind seine bilder so gut dass
sie von echten quasi nicht mehr zu
unterscheiden sind auch nicht von uns
menschen
das ganze kann man sich aber auch
mathematisch veranschaulichen also wenn
wir daten betrachten dann folgen die
irgendwelchen verteilung und zunächst
haben wir die verteilung der echten
daten diesen krieg das gern ein
gefüttert und dann gibt es die
verteilung von dem generator und
manchmal stimmt die natürlich nicht
überein dass hat nichts was ja noch
nicht gelernt wie ich gern aussehen und
der diskriminierung der versucht immer
die beiden verteilung zu unterscheiden
und je länger weil die beiden gegner
trainiert desto mehr gleicht sich die
verteilung von generator der echten
datenverteilung an
und wenn man die dann richtig gelernt
hat dann karte distributor gar keine
chance mehr dann kann er gar nicht mehr
unterscheiden ob jetzt ein echter laden
punkt oder ein gefälschter vorliegt das
klingt vielleicht etwas kompliziert
bedeutet aber eigentlich nur dass das
kann die unterliegende verteilung
gelernt hat und das ist mega cool denn
damit kann man dann auch zwischen den
datenpunkten interpolieren das bedeutet
dass wir uns jeden beliebigen punkt
zwischen null und eins aussuchen können
und uns das kann dann einen
entsprechenden wert ausspuckt den es
dafür generiert besonders anschaulich
kann man das an gesichtern beobachten
wenn das dann erst einmal gelernt hat
wie ein gesicht aussieht dann können wir
jeden beliebigen punkt zwischen zwei
gesichtern generieren lassen und das ist
echt creepy aber auch irgendwie
beeindruckend diese gesichter sehen alle
ziemlich echt aus aber sie existieren
nicht in der realen welt
okay das ist ja alles mega cool aber was
bringt uns das denn jetzt wirklich also
in der echten welt wir wollen nicht nur
bilder von gesichtern oder von äpfeln
kreieren
nun zum einen kann man damit auch so
coole sachen machen wie in unserer folge
über kay und kunst die ihr euch hier
ansehen könnt
aber auch das ist ja irgendwo eine
spielerei also lasst uns mal über
synthetische medizinische daten sprechen
drei schritte zurück machine learning
kann genutzt werden um medizinische
daten zu analysieren und dort muster
oder auch anomalien zu finden
modelle können zum beispiel hautkrebs in
fotos oder tumore in radiologischen
daten erkennen und das teilweise besser
als ärzte
das ist natürlich super hilfreich wie
ich auch schon in meinem video über ki
in der medizin erklärt habe zum training
dieser super hilfreichen algorithmen
werden aber sehr große datenmengen
benötigt die datensätze eines einzelnen
krankenhauses reichen da oft nicht aus
und selbst wenn ist es immer besser wenn
mehr samples verfügbar sind weil dann
auch seltenere krankheitsbilder mit
abgedeckt sind
jetzt könnte man natürlich auf die idee
kommen mehrere datensätze aus
verschiedenen kliniken zu kombinieren
aber aus datenschutzgründen dürfen
kliniken ihre patientendaten meistens
nicht weitergeben und das problem können
wir lösen indem ihr generative modelle
benutzten um synthetische medizinische
daten zu erzeugen
das sind eine künstliche daten in den
keller passiert abgebildet ist das
datenschutzproblem also nicht besteht
zum beispiel ein team von
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
vom max planck institut in tübingen und
der eth zürich hat künstliche lungen ct
bilder erstellt und gehirn mrt bilder
und mediziner konnten die nicht von
echten bildern unterscheiden und das ist
halt megatrucks diese lungen bilder die
wir hier sehen
die gibt es nicht es gibt keinen
patienten dem diese lunge hier gehört
und die bilder sind trotzdem so
realistisch dass profis sie nicht von
echten unterscheiden können
das ist natürlich unglaublich wertvoll
denn diese daten kann man jetzt nutzen
um zum beispiel ein neues modell zu
trainieren
ein problem bei der sache ist allerdings
dass wenn wir unser modell ist zum
beispiel auf einem kleinen krankenhaus
auf dem land trainieren
und da die altersstruktur der
bevölkerung eine andere ist als in
berlin
bei unser modell in berlin dann
natürlich auch nur beschränkt einsetzen
können und hier stoßen wir auf ein
fundamentales problem von maschinellem
lernen
die modelle sind nur so gut wie die
daten mit denen sie trainiert werden
auch denken wir menschen zum beispiel
dass ein algorithmus etwas verstanden
hat während er in wirklichkeit nur auf
ein korrelieren das phänomen achtet
außerdem untersucht nur in tübingen auf
generativen modelle auch wirklich
konzepte oder zusammenhänge verstehen
können ob zum beispiel ein modell lernen
kann was wirklich ein apfel ist und das
ist nämlich gar nicht so einfach wenn
wir menschen das wort apfel hören dann
haben wir direkt ein konkretes bild im
kopf und verstehen sogar das konzept
dahinter
äpfel haben generell einen stil sind
meistens rund und haben eine grüne oder
rote färbung die frage die uns in der
nächsten folge beschäftigen wird ist hat
das generative modell eine ähnliche
darstellung eines apfels gelernt hat der
algorithmus wirklich verstanden was ein
apfel ist abonniert den kanal um diese
zweite folge nicht zu verpassen und
aktiviert auch gerne die glocke dann
werdet ihr benachrichtigt sobald dieses
video online geht ansonsten vielen dank
an annika und das max planck institut
für intelligente systeme für die
wunderbare zusammenarbeit und an euch
vielen dank fürs zuschauen und bis zum
nächsten mal bleibt neugierig patrick